point let's bring in maria bartoromo
anchor of sunday morning futures and
mornings with maria maria good morning
to you a pretty good report first the
news what is in it job's number here it
is 431 000 we expected a little higher
number unemployment rate dropped
slightly 3.6 percent pretty good report
maria how do you read it today good
morning
bill sandra great to see you both thanks
so much it is a pretty good report we
want to see this kind of job creation
month over month for sure even though it
was shy of the most economist
expectations which called for 490 000
jobs added to the economy in the month
of march always good to see the
unemployment rate moving lower it did
move lower by 3.6 percent my issue with
this report is a big portion of the jobs
created in the month of march were
low-paying jobs you're talking about
jobs in leisure hospitality retail these
are low-paying jobs and if you zero in
on the data behind the headlines in this
report we see that wages moved up
four-tenths of a percent this is not
keeping up with inflation year over year
you're talking about wages moving up
about five and a half percent as you
both know inflation is running at eight
percent so once again we see disposable
income being zapped by the cost of
inflation and that is evident in this
report also evidence in this report is
an increase in the participation rate
the participation rate increasing uh up
fractionally to a level of 62.4 that's
good that more people are coming back to
work but it also suggests that some
people are realizing they have to get
back to work to deal with the inflation
numbers so again good job growth good
indication for the economy does not take
away the worries about recession does
not take away the worries about
inflation which remain at 40-year highs
guys you know we would normally maria
historically be celebrating the fact
that average hourly earnings over the
past 12 months are up 5.6
that's great for the average american
worker if it weren't for
inflation at 7.9 so everything more that
the american worker is earning is
getting wiped out by the high price of
just about everything and maria you dig
into all of this and now you see the
answer to these sky high gas prices to
tap the strategic petroleum reserve and
we all know that is putting band-aid on
a problem even just in the most recent
releases we've only seen prices continue
to go up after the release of those
reserves so what is this move on the
part of the white house
well it's a great point that you make
and i know that you've studied energy
sandra for many many years and know this
market cold the bottom line is when you
see a band-aid fixed it's only going to
go back up after a little cool-off
period and that's what we have been
seeing this is the third time that the
president has reached into the strategic
petroleum reserve and it hasn't worked
before because every time he has
released oil from the strategic reserve
oil prices eventually after a little
cooling off period went back to high so
we'll see if that happens again that's
why most observers want to see
fundamental change in policy in
structure in terms of supply and demand
what does that mean it means dealing
with drillers not killers dealing with
american companies that can actually
drill for the product and get back to
business the way they were making the u
s energy independence that will be the
long-term solution not a short-term move
that may pressure prices lower over the
near term but longer term we see a
reversal to back up to elevated prices
because of those supply demand dynamics
yeah just one last point here and the
president tried to explain it yesterday
i'm just reading from the newsweek piece
uh verbatim it says the spike in gas
prices are largely a result of russia's
invasion of ukraine uh though only about
three percent of the us's oil imports
come from russia
the president didn't even say that much
maria
that reporting is so incomplete
it's totally incomplete and it is
impossible to say that the reason
gasoline prices are where they are is
because of putin covid the oil companies
whatever you want to say no we look at
the inflation timeline that we went back
and showed throughout the show this
morning on mornings with maria on fox
business and you can clearly see that
when president biden took office the
inflation rate was at 1.4 percent by
march of that year when he signed into
law the covid relief package it was up
to 2.6
by july of that year it was up to six
and a half percent because the democrats
were pushing another spending package
all the way up to 3.9 trillion dollars
it kept inching up all the way to this
year when of course we saw the invasion
which did put a premium on it it got up
to 7.9 percent but it started way before
russia invaded ukraine guys thank you
maria we'll see you on sunday okay maria
bartoromo with us nice to see you